ja vielen dank schon netz hier in
osterhofen feiert die afg ihren
politischen aschermittwoch genauso wie
das original der csu mit blasmusik und
weißwurst und bier und es ist
mittlerweile der größte politische
aschermittwoch ihren bayern nach der csu
und natürlich steht auch diese
veranstaltung im zeichen der europawahl
hauptredner ist jörg leuten und wir
zeigen nicht nur diese rede sondern auch
die von guido reil wir zum ersten mal
auf einen politischen aschermittwoch in
bayern redet der ist westfale mitglied
des bundesvorstands auf platz zwei der
europaliste und ehemaliger
sozialdemokraten grüß gott
servus habe die ihre glück ab osterhofen
[Applaus]
also ich hab ich habe gänsehaut ich bin
unglaublich glücklich hier heute stehen
zu dürfen vor dieser fantastischen
kulisse vor diesen vielen freundlichen
menschen und ich bin unglaublich
glücklich dass ihr mich so freundlich
begrüßt habt den alten größen
unglaublich und ich denke mal da sind
ganz deutliches zeichen die afg spaltet
nicht die afg vereint die afg vereint
alle patriotischen kräfte in deutschland
liebe freunde
[Applaus]
oder als ich gestern losgefahren bin von
zu hause da hat meine frau den koffer
für mich gepackt hat oft bei uns noch
ganz konservativ da hat sie mich gefragt
was ich denn für ein sakko mehr möchte
dann sage ich hör mal weißt du noch wo
der alte räder mantel liegt guck dich
nicht ganz entsetzt an und sagt bist du
verrückt da habe ich gesagt ich fahre
nach bayern die sind ja alle verrückt ja
alles was wir wollen ist eigentlich nur
mit den ganzen wahnsinn aufhören und ich
bin auch ganz glücklich dass ich hier
heute als erster reden darf dann krieg
ich nämlich als erster redner bier und
da freue ich mich schon drauf
ja ist heute meine erste rede auf einen
politischen aschermittwoch und worum
geht es da und mit dem politischen
gegner hart ins gericht zu gehen bisher
lustig zu sein
einiges zu überspitzen ja und bevor man
so richtig kritisiert sollte man
vielleicht auch positives sagen also ich
glaube tatsächlich dass die regierung
bald richtig gemacht habe wo ihr die
allermeisten von uns frauen sagen nee da
spinnt wir haben ja jetzt drei
geschlechter in deutschland es gibt
diverse da sagen die meisten von euch
sind die verrückt geworden gibt keine
wichtigeren probleme in unserem land wie
kinderarmut obdachlosigkeit oder unsere
infrastruktur warum kümmern wir uns
immer um dinge die 0,2 prozent der
bevölkerung betreffen
und warum macht man sich auch nie
gedanken was solche regelungen für
konsequenzen haben müssten zum beispiel
dass wir uns jetzt überall in
deutschland gedanken darüber machen ob
öffentliche gebäude ob kindergärten und
schulen
der dritte toilette bekommen und auf die
milliarden kosten
so hat interessiert alles kein schwein
man macht erstmals umgesetzt aber ich
verstehe die da so ein bisschen denn man
muss immer gucken in watt von umfeld
bewegen sich menschen die daten
schließen
also ich persönlich kenne es nicht so
viele diverse ich glaube ihr auch nicht
aber noch nicht so viele kennen gelernt
aber wenn ich mich da im bund
cook
[Musik]
wenn ich da genau hingucken wenn ich sie
sehe
diese liebreizenden charmanten
liebevollen zauberhaften wesen diese
merkel diese roth diesen a list wir sind
hofreiter diesen cars da sehe ich sie
[Applaus]
also es gibt tatsächlich anscheinend
diverse und dann brachten so gesetze
wiedersehen so gesetz des wahnsinns ja
die politischen gegner also die
schwatten lasse ich mal heute aus bevor
die kriegen glaube ich noch genug für
mütze zur fdp zu diesen unterhalten
model fehlt mir ein
er hat gesagt der hat gesagt besser gar
nicht regieren als volk regieren
das hat auch der ein oder andere
verstanden nun jetzt macht der
opposition nach dem motto besser falsche
opposition zu machen als richtig
abzustimmen und richtig abzustimmen wer
in vielen punkten mit der afg system
leder enthalten die sich lieber sein
halten die sich einfach
und so eine partei die sich nur wegduckt
die nicht regieren möchte die auf keiner
position machen will die braucht kein
mensch
und die nächste werbekampagne mit
irgendwelchen unterhemden wird der afg
wetter spd ist fdp auch nicht mehr
weiterhelfen die sind für mich völlig
sinnlos die braucht kein mensch
wenn meine freunde von den linken
da passiert etwas ganz tolles da gibt es
jetzt eine bewegung die nennt sich
aufwachen aufstehen aufstehen also leute
wenn irgendwann überhaupt nicht zu
linken passt dann ist auch stehen und
schon gar nicht früh
das ist ja völlig widersinnig und dass
wir seit einführung des euros hier in
deutschland turbokapitalismus erleben
dann haben wir noch gar nicht gemerkt da
sind sich noch gar nicht aufgewacht also
die kollegen bleiben auch die braucht
kein mensch mehr in deutschland ja und
dann unser lieblingsgegner die grünen
wir bereiten uns hier alle viel freude
also die grünen
für mich sind die grünen keine partei
die grünen sind eine
glaubensgemeinschaft hat ist der
religion und die glauben da irgendwas
aber solche leute haben wir eine kirche
zu suchen oder eine kommune aber nicht
in den deutschen parlamenten
und wenn ihr euch mal so die thematiken
der grünen ankunft in den letzten
jahrzehnten reagieren genau wie der
sekte die profizeit nämlich ständen
nicht den weltuntergang
wir haben angefangen mit dem waldsterben
der wald ist nicht gestorben ende der
80er hat uns eine eiszeit bedroht haben
viele schon verdrängt aber konterte die
nachlesen
wir wurden auch von einer eiszeit
bedroht in den 90ern sind wir
reihenweise gestorben werden dem
ozonloch und diese hätten weiter klima
und immer bewahren uns den grünen vor
allem katastrophen wenn die passieren
nicht so funktionieren sekten und ich
meine ganz klar die sollen uns
anständige menschen hier in ruhe lassen
die so in form ihrer kommune leben
[Applaus]
da könnte dann nach ihren fassungen
leben was so grüne gerne mache und da
können sie den ganzen tag mit
kinderspielen nur dort naturprodukte zu
sich nehmen die das bewusstsein erhält
nach den klimawandel antanzen
wo bitte stellt euch hat jetzt nicht vor
die bilder kriegt ihr nicht mehr aus dem
kopf die bildergeschichte liebe aus kopf
ja die grünen
und dann gibt es da noch eine ehemals
stolze volkspartei der ich lange die
treue gehalten hat weil ich lange
geglaubt habt diese partei setzt sich
ein für meine leute für die arbeiter und
für die kleinen leute
aber ich musste erkennen und dann waren
langer schwerer weg dass keine andere
partei in deutschland die arbeiter und
die kleinen leute so verraten und
verkauft hat wie die spd
[Applaus]
man muss sich nur mal diese person
angucken und dann dahinter legen da
zieht arbeiterführer man stellt sich
schon arbeiterführer vor
und dann muss man sich angucken diesem
maß diesen stegener da ist der
unsympathische politiker in deutschland
für mich also möchte ich mal jetzt wenn
jetzt wenn ich mir jetzt so einen
richtig bösen rechtsradikalen aus denken
würde
der song talkshow sitzt also für mich
weder ter stegen also unsympathischer
kammer nicht gucken und aggressiver kann
man nicht sprechen
dann gibt es immer noch martin schulz
viele leser noch bekannt als der schutz
zug also als das schulze vor zwei jahren
unser los gefahren ist habe ich gesagt
vor zwei jahren es fährt ein zug nach
nirgendwo mit dir als blinder passagier
unter schock ist mittlerweile auf dem
abstellgleis der geschichte und trotzdem
möchte der sich noch mal einbringen und
die spd im europa wahlkampf unterstützen
ja kann meiner partei noch mehr schaden
kriegt er gilt dafür wird er von fremden
mächten gesteuert und kann man ja erst
gar nicht mehr glauben kein politiker
ist unglaubwürdiger wie dieser martin
schulz
aber man kann ja nicht nur schlecht
sprüchen ich muss in einer sache auch
mal meine bewunderung ausdrücken
also mal los und kann dieser martin
schulz anscheinend denn er hat es
tatsächlich geschafft an 365 tage für
das europäische parlament zu arbeiten
und an 365 tagen im jahr ist es wieder
zu kassieren
respekt so jemand habe ich noch nicht
kennengelernt er war heiligabend oder
silvester ostern da war immer da 365
tage im jahr
und da frage ich mich wie ich so was
überhaupt möglich wie kann einer ersten
zu bescheißen und zweitens warum ist er
überhaupt noch aktiver politiker warum
muss da noch nicht gehen aber dann sind
wir auch beim thema europa da werde ich
ja bald auch eine gewisse rolle spielen
und ich habe mir da ziele gesetzt also
ich will irgendwie versuchen ziemlich
nahe an diese 365 tage zu kommen ich
glaube ich werde es schaffen
aber man muss auch ehrgeiz haben man
muss auch ehrgeiz haben nur ich werde
euch auch ganz genau sagen wie ich das
geschafft habe ich das irgendwie raus
und dann muss ich mich tatsächlich ist
mit völlig neuen dingen beschaffen
ich werde der andere wird kennenlernen
ich mit vielen dingen beschäftigen die
ich gar nicht kennen
deswegen bin ich dabei bin schon vor zu
bilden dinge zu erfahren
ich bin jetzt gerade dabei mir zu
überlegen was ist denn es besser kaufe
ich mir 911 turbo oder mercedes sl ich
muss ja mit meiner kohle irgendwohin
also irgendwo muss das viele geld hin
oder muss man sich mit gewissen dingen
beschäftigen und ich habe auch große
angst davor mich vielleicht falschen
verhalten
ich frage mich muss ich für junkers
jetzt schon um 12 uhr anfangen zu laufen
[Applaus]
also bei uns im ruhrgebiet gibt es den
spruch kein bier vor 4
ihr seht dass hier ein bisschen anders
ich weiß aber ich möchte mich gerne an
regeln halten
so habe ich gehört abends ist man
regelmäßig unterwegs mit lobbyisten
da soll nochmal cokxxx [__] geben da
frag ich mich muss ich das jetzt
wirklich jeden abend machen ich bin alt
es habe ich aber überhaupt noch ich muss
meine gesundheit denken also ich bin ja
bereit mich zu opfer für mein land
aber man darf es nicht übertreiben ja
also in europa in brüssel straßburg
dagegen der menge komische dinge ab und
die aufgabe von uns ist den finger in
die wunde zu legen die aufgabe von uns
ist es den wahnsinn aufzubieten die
ganze dekadenz aufzudecken und dann
haben einige jahr
[Applaus]
einige haben gefragt bist du denn der
richtige für brüssel ist die länder
qualifiziert und ich sag ja denn in
brüssel habe ich keine halbe stunde
redezeit oder sieben minuten wie im
bundestag da habe ich eine minute und
meiner wenigen talente ist das
komplizierte sachverhalte in ganz
wenigen sätze zu sagen wenn mich jetzt
einer fragt was ist deine qualifikation
für brüssel
leute ich habe geschäftsführer
jugendkreis und ich bin kommt für
schultz
die hat kein bisschen ja dann wurde ich
noch ein paar worte verlieren zum
verfassungsschutz
der verfassungsschutz ist dafür da um zu
prüfen ob menschen vereine gruppen oder
vereister parteien gibt die gegen unsere
freiheitlich demokratische grundordnung
sind und da fährt denn tatsächlich nach
vier jahren ein dass sich seine partei
gegründet hat es geschafft hat in allen
landtagen einzuziehen und im deutschen
bundestag
und dann haben sie sich gedacht mensch
jetzt müssen wir am anfang unserer
arbeit zu machen
nach sechs jahre alt wir haben sechs
jahre auf den boden gelegt und den vier
jetzt nach sechs jahren auf das einmal
prüfen müssen
also ich helfe gerne ich will den leuten
auch die arbeit nicht so schwer machen
und deswegen möchte ich den freunden vom
verfassungsschutz war so ein bisschen
was über mein tagesablauf sagen und wenn
ich so mache also ich zum beispiel esse
gerne negerkuss putin
und ich kann euch versprechen heute gibt
es noch immer steht seit gestern bin ich
über die autobahn gefahren
es war die a 45 und a ab morgen auch
einige interviews gegeben
da wurde ich gefragt was macht denn die
afg zuerst wenn sie eine verantwortung
kommt ich sage wie was ist das denn für
eine frage dann ist doch klar überfallen
polen guckt euch mal die frauen an
und dann wurde ich noch gefragt nach
meinem persönlichen zielen man muss ja
immer ziel und römer haben da sag ich
auch was ist das denn für eine frage die
weltherrschaft was uns ich bin mal was
so nicht sonst holen
und selbstverständlich will ich unseren
guten alten kaiser wilhelm wiederhaben
selbstverständlich so und jetzt mein
vielleicht die ein oder anderen
medienvertreter mensch der reihe
verzieren
liebe freunde ihr verarscht uns 365 tage
im jahr
[Applaus]
die blockparteien gez medien die
gewerkschaften die kirchen alle die
irgendwie mit spielen alle die an den
futtertrögen sind alle die mit saugen
wollen all die verarschen und
anständigen menschen die hier arbeiten
sind sich an unsere gesetze halten und
treu zu ihrem land und kultur steht all
die forschen
und wir die afd wir sind die einzigen
die einzigen die dagegenhalten und eines
verspreche ich euch
wir werden nicht zurückweichen für uns
gibt es nur eine richtung
wir werden die reihen geschlossen halten
und wir werden nach vorne gehen schritt
für schritt werden wir nach vorne gehen
weil wir deutschland lieben weil wir
europa lieben weil wir unsere kultur
lieben weil wir stehen zu den christlich
abendländischen werten weil wir stehen
zur aufklärung zum humanismus wir stehen
für eine bunte und freiheitliche
gesellschaft wir lieben unsere heimat
die af.de glück auf ihre freunde
[Applaus]